joining us now with more reaction former
FBI special agent Nicole Parker Nicole
thank you so much for joining us
um you know last year uh there was sort
of a chilling effect wasn't there when a
I remember the Attorney General Garland
put out a memo kind of putting everybody
in the FBI on unnoticed what did you
take when you saw that memo that he put
out
Jason we all remember this
um I was in August of 2022 and we
received several emails in one day which
was you know kind of different and we
all remember that there was one
particular email that discussed reaching
out to Congress and you know the
restrictions and the you know directions
on FBI employees reaching out directly
to Congress and I think a lot of us were
very confused by it we're we were
wondering why are we receiving this but
you didn't even want to ask you didn't
even want to go to the legal department
to ask but it meant because then that
might imply that maybe you had a
question and then it put a Target on
your back but it was very obvious that a
lot of employees were very disturbed by
that and it kind of gave a chilling
effect do not speak up and although they
say that's not what that was for that's
how many people felt yeah right yeah I
can tell you it says somebody who was in
Congress and involved in oversight I got
to tell you it was outrageous that they
did that because I think it was there my
personal opinion the one number one
thing it was was supposed to do is
intimidate people from who are thinking
about coming forward saying don't you
dare you're going to hate it it's going
to ruin your career nevertheless now
that look I I used to think that it was
just a couple of people at the top top
of the food chain that were the problem
but it seems more pervasive than that
what's your perspective how pervasive is
this politicalization of the Department
of Justice and specifically the FBI
you know I've always believed that it
does start at the top in Washington DC
it starts in the top and it starts with
executive management or those on the
seventh floor and it kind of trickles
down and I think that the the thing with
the FBI is that it used to be more of a
criminal agency and from you know the
difference that post 911 it turned in
kind of more of an Intel agency and
there's a big drive for intelligence and
that seems to be the side of the house
that tends to have a lot of the the
issues and concerns I I think it would
be best if the FBI just got back to
fighting crime there are so many amazing
agents that are fighting crime you know
we celebrate National Police Week this
week my very dear friend special agent
Laura schwarzenberger was killed in the
line of duty protecting children from a
child predator yeah that is what the FBI
should be doing while she's doing that
in the meantime there's people up in DC
that are politicizing the FBI and it's
it's just completely disrespectful to to
her and tarnishes her Legacy it's not
okay yeah I mean yeah Peter struct is in
charge of counterintelligence for the
United States he sends ten thousand ten
thousand text messages to somebody he's
evidently having in a bear with he's
obviously not focused on you know
counterterrorism maybe like the Chinese
and the Russians what they're actually
doing and then trying to go after and
make sure that Donald Trump doesn't
become the president that's not
counterintelligence that is counter to
what he should have been doing as a
senior person at the FBI but those are
my words and uh listen I do appreciate
your prayer your service to our country
and thanks for joining us tonight on
Hannity do appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else